- Pour ln estivale est synonyme
de grandes aventures
immortalisées dans les camps de
jour et les camps de vacances.
Mais voilà que plusieurs
frappentfrappentfrappentfrappent
certaines institutions.
Ici, au camp Ouareau,
dans Lanaudière, au moins
11 moniteurs et deux aspirants
à la COVID-19.
La direction a demandé
aux parents de venir chercher
leurs enfants aujourd'hui.
- Elle était partie pour
c'est terminé.
La santé publique avant tout!
- C'est la vie, mais
je comprends qu'il y a peut-être
des enjeux avec le personnel.
C'est sûr, s'ils font ça toute
la saison, ça va être difficile!
JACQUI RAILL,
directrice camp Ouareau
- Les parents vraiment
ont compris vraiment pourquoi
on a pris cette décision,
parce que c'est pour la sécurité
des enfants.
- L'endroit devrait rouvrir
le 13 juillet prochain.
Au moins deux autres camps
au Québec ont dû fermer
cette semaine dont le camp de
jour à Sept-Îles, où 15 membres
du personnel ont la COVID-19.
CINDY HOUNSELL, superviseur
loisirs, Ville de Sept-Îles
- La pénurie de la main-d'oeuvre
fait en sorte qu'on n'a pas
30 moniteurs qui attendent
en arrière dans la listela liste
pour remplacer ceux qui sont
en isolement. Donc, la situation
fait en sorte que, rapidement,
on se retrouve à la solution
d'annulevités.
- Par voie de communiqué,
la santé publique rappelle
que la décision de fermer
ou non un camp revient
ionnaires de
l'établissement.
ERIC BEAUCHEMIN, DG,
Association des camps du Québec
- Je vous rappelle qu'on a opérn
en camps de vacances,
mais on avait au préalable
les tests PCR pour les campeurs.
Est-ce que c'est une mesure
ERIC BEAUCHEMIN, D
Association des camps du Québec
- Je vous rappelle qu'on a opéré
l'été dernier sans éclosion
en camps de vacances,
mais on réalable
les tests PCR pour les campeurs.
Est-ce que c'est une mesure
qu'on peut remettre en place?
On aimerait ça, par contre,
mettre fémorragie. Nous,
on veut rencontrer la santé
publique dès aujourd'hui.
- Québec promet de rencontrer
les représentants de
rie prochainement.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,